superhero movies are a major movie
staple but they weren't always popular
throughout the 1970s 80's and 90's movie
and television producers adapted comics
titles with varying degrees of success
for every Superman or Batman that were a
half-dozen heroes who flocked here are a
few superhero movies most people have
completely forgotten about the shadow
this 1994 Alec Baldwin vehicle adapted
the 1930s pulp hero to the big screen
Lamont Cranston is a wealthy playboy who
as the shadow uses a handful of mystical
powers such as mind control to fight
crime Universal Studios poured a lot of
money into what it wanted to be a big
franchise but they didn't spend quite
enough on the story about a descendant
of Genghis Khan determined to detonate
an atomic bomb the ultimately just
wasn't a huge built-in audience for a
property that was popular before most of
its potential consumers were even alive
The Phantom based on the classic comic
strip 1996 is the Phantom starring Billy
Zane as kit Walker another wealthy
playboy who secretly fights crime as a
masked hero but let's be honest it's
hard to take a hero seriously whilst
he's running around in a goofy purple
jumpsuit if you're daring enough to
watch The Phantom book for an early
performance from Catherine zeta-jones as
the villains female sidekick get a good
luck
Fantastic Four it's clobberin time ten
years before 20th Century Fox made its
first fantastic full movie legendary
b-movie producer Roger Corman developed
his own super low-budget adaptation few
people have saw it because it was never
officially released in theaters or on
video but bootleg copies have been
widely available at comic conventions
and online it was only ever made in the
first place so that the studio could
retain the rights to the characters
before they expired Doctor Strange years
before making his 2016 big-screen debut
Marvel's Doctor Strange starred in a
1978 made-for-tv movie it tells the
origin story of strange played by
journeyman actor Peter Hooten who
transforms from being a medical doctor
into a sorcerer the effects are pretty
dated and the costumes look like they
came out of a circus one notable thing
about the 1978 strange a young foxy
Jessica Walter portrays the villain
Morgan la Fey
but these days you're probably more
likely to recognize her as Lucille Bluth
from Arrested Development and the voice
of Mallory from Archer The Punisher if
you need to watch Dolph Lundgren murder
dozens of yakuza then the 1989
adaptation of Marvel's The Punisher is
right up your alley
Lundgren plays Frank Castle a grieving
cop who avenges his family's death the
greatest fight in the film however maybe
longer ins struggle with the English
language but in the year ago dark man
Liam Neeson portrays scientist Peyton
Westlake whose life is forever altered
after he's attacked by ruthless mobsters
and left horribly scarred in a
convenient twist he's also now super
strong and resistant to pain allowing
him to pay back those who've wronged him
Sam Raimi director of the Evil Dead and
original spider-man movies co-wrote and
directed dark man it's got many
hallmarks of his work including
slapstick humor over-the-top action
of course a cameo from Bruce Campbell a
bunch of Captain America movies in 2011
Captain America the First Avenger was a
hit but the First Avenger wasn't
actually the first Captain America movie
hmm not by a long shot
filmed in 1990 and released on video two
years later Captain America starred Matt
Salinger son of the legendary reclusive
author JD Salinger it tells the
now-familiar tale of would be soldiers
Steve Rogers who becomes the superhero
and fights his Nazi nemesis the Red
Skull and back in 1979 CBS Edie two
made-for-tv movies appropriately titled
Captain America and Captain America 2
both starred b-movie action king
red-brown as cap the daredevil stunts
Evel Knievel was popular for at the time
is why Captain America spends so much of
his time on a motorcycle condorman in
this 1981 Disney movie
a guy named woody Wilkins is a comic
book artist who decided to become a real
world version of his creation he comes
to the attention of the CIA and the
agency recruits Wilkins for a mission to
save a beautiful KGB agent who plants
the defect to the United States and
apparently in a bid to fully waste
taxpayers money they build Wilkins his
own condorman themed car and boat you
know for a guy who can fly various 70
spider-man movies Spiderman was the star
of a made-for-tv movie in the late 1970s
called appropriately spider-man the
90-minute film served as the pilot to
the CBS show the amazing spider-man
episodes from the show's two season run
were eventually repackaged as standalone
movies and sold on video around the
world as spider-man Strikes Back and
spider-man the Dragons challenge though
the show must have been pretty cool for
comic fans at the time let's just say it
hasn't aged very well Swamp Thing the
return of The Swamp Thing a scientist is
transformed into Swamp Thing after
soldiers working for the evil Anton
arcane
Oh daddy's laboratory in the Louisiana
bayou the results are more corny than
horrific with some pre cheap special
effects even for 1982 and yet a sequel
called the return of Swamp Thing was
produced in 1989 this time the scientist
turned walking lilypad must once again
defeat his nemesis Anton arcane who
somehow survived being horrific aliy
mutated in the first movie the only
positive thing to say about the return
of Swamp Thing is that the costumes look
a little better well that and the
superhot romance between Swamp Thing and
a young Heather Locklear
well thanks for watching subscribe to
our YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which of these
movies you remember after all